today i'm going to be speaking with ward
farnsworth who is dean of the university
of texas law school and also author of
the socratic method a practitioner's
handbook it's so great to have you on
today i really appreciate it
thanks for having me david good to be
here so i talk about the socratic method
with my audience frequently and i think
maybe the best place to start would be
when we say socratic we're there's in in
that word we're talking about socrates
so maybe we can start with the origins
of of why this is this is a method
attributed to socrates and what it is
sure well um
when people talk about the socratic
method in socrates what they usually
mean is
the style of dialogue and discourse and
thinking that you see displayed by
socrates in the dialogues of plato we
don't really know much about the real
socrates whether that's how we talked we
know that's how the literary socrates
talk and that's the model for the
socratic method and the model is
characterized by
uh questions but particular types of
questions meant to elicit certain type
of thinking can you talk us through that
a little bit
yeah i think the socratic method is the
greatest tool there is for for critical
thinking and for testing
people's views it has a lot of features
and they're hard to summarize quickly
but usually what socrates is trying to
do is
work with the beliefs of the person he's
talking to so socrates doesn't usually
say you're wrong
he says
can we agree
on this
can we agree on that
well but but if you if we agree on those
things then what about this other thing
that you said it seems like there's a uh
tension there or an issue so he
basically talks people into
contradiction with themselves which is a
to me a distinctly uh effective way of
working with people you don't agree with
one of the things that sometimes is
frustrating in the modern landscape is
you might get someone to contradict
themselves but they seem
unable to recognize that they've
contradicted themselves and so for
example we we see this frequently when i
will talk to people who say
that trump is actually the president and
it's joe biden's fault that gas prices
are high it's like well if joe biden's
not really the president how could it be
his fault that gas prices are high
that's sort of the contradiction
but sometimes people seem to lack an
ability to even understand the
contradiction how would the socratic
method address that
well first of all
if they don't think there's a
contradiction
then i and i'm the one using the method
then my feeling is that's on me my
questions have not been skillful enough
or maybe i'm wrong maybe there isn't a
contradiction they don't think there is
one because it looks like there's one to
you but what they mean when they say
donald trump's really president isn't
what you think they mean they mean this
and you think they mean that and so
there's something additional about their
meaning that you've got to get to the
bottom of uh that
i just think the right way to think
about this is
always ask whether if you're not making
headway it's really on them take
responsibility and see if you can be
more empathetic and try to understand
what they mean or what they're thinking
that's that's an important part of the
socratic method is
you're trying to get people to come
around to your way of thinking and
before you can do that you kind of got
to come around to their way of thinking
or really understand it and not just not
just like what passes for thoughts not
what not what passes for thought in the
minds of these people you think are
idiots but but how they actually look at
the world and why it makes sense to them
and once you really get that it's much
easier from that standpoint to then uh
bring them around to something that's
more like the way you look at things
one of the things that seems important
in the socratic method is a sort of
humility about our own beliefs and it
seems that the approach of asking
questions
can be humble in a sense because you're
you're really trying to learn more about
what the other person believes even if
your ultimate goal is that you suspect
they're wrong and you want to change
their mind at the same time there's
sometimes the assumption that it's more
persuasive to appear more confident in
in what you believe so is there a
balance that needs to be struck or is it
just not true that it's more persuasive
to be confident
well i suppose it's hard to generalize
i'm sure there are people who are very
persuaded by confidence and not by
humility but the socratic method in any
event is is founded on humility i mean i
know the socratic method sounds
fundamentally like a technique for
questioning other people and for trying
to bring them around and it's very
powerful for that but to me first and
foremost it's a style of thought that if
you're if you really care about these
things you try to use yourself so you're
also you're questioning what you think
and you're wondering if maybe you're
wrong and so uh when you're talking to
people you're trying to help
questioning for them to see things your
way but you're also alert to the idea
that maybe you have something to learn
from them and i think that that one
byproduct of that approach is that if
you're humble in that way you're more
likely to make headway with others but
you're also more likely to make headway
and seeing your own uh
short-sightedness which is of course
something we should all want
can can we talk through in practice how
this might sort of
appear in if it's happening at you know
the thanksgiving table is often the one
people call in they say i know my uncle
believes that let's i mean we could just
stick with my uncle believes trump won
he just believes it was stolen he
believes joe biden stole it and he's
going to bring it up and he's going to
say can you guys believe
what joe biden was able to get away with
and people want sort of a framework with
which they can without upsetting people
without ruining relationships start a
gentle socratic inquiry what types of
questions might we we ask in that
situation well
good question i mean the first question
is you know is it worthwhile to
thanksgiving table to try to chase this
down let's assume it is let's assume it
is interesting we'll assume it is but i
just mean you can be socratic about the
the value of using these methods in a
certain moment that's but but putting
that to one side yeah um
look i mean to me the goal is always can
you find some common ground can you find
something you agree on that you can then
build from so saying something like uh
uh
you know look what here's what i'm
interested in what would you be willing
to count as evidence
that the election wasn't stolen
or or or what's or what do you want to
count as evidence of anything i mean
like like let's just take something
that's less controversial and just see
if we can agree on that how do you know
that somebody else won the presidential
election let's talk let's talk about an
election we can agree on right how do
you know who won that election i'm just
interested i mean i'm really wondering
how do you think about that because in
the in the sense we don't know all we
know is what we read in the paper so how
what makes you so sure that somebody you
like ever that ever that donald trump
won the first election
and and let them explain that for a
while and you say okay so that's
interesting so
i guess what i'm wondering now is of
those things you mentioned how many of
those things are not also present
in the election you are worried about
and so trying to find an election you
can agree on before you start talking
about election you can't agree on i
think is is a helpful approach and i
would just use that approach in general
is try to find a case you can agree on
and then talk through what that case is
about and then try to use what you've
established in your in your easy case to
sort of gently ask about the hard case
that's really interesting it seems
there's maybe in thinking about the
empathy component there as well there
might be an opportunity also to find
common ground in this conversation to
say do do are we on the same page that
we both want whoever really won to be
the president right are we on the same
page that that that's right that's
ultimately what we want we want to know
who really won but that person should
definitely be the president it seems
that might also be useful
definitely but then of course
so after i think everybody would agree
on that that's a good thing to start
with and then then you'd say okay now
now the question is what does it mean to
say somebody really won yeah like do you
what do you mean somebody who got the
most popular vote or do you mean the
person who won the electoral college
forget about trump for a minute just
what do we mean in general
and you keep trying to build agreements
on things and once you have these
agreements in place you narrow
everything down and you know i still
think that i mean
in these conversations of course you're
always hopefully thinking look maybe
i'll learn something and you can say to
the person honestly let me tell you if
this election was stolen i want to know
i mean i don't want to live under a
stolen election i'm sure you don't
either david right so if there's any
evidence that this was stolen i i
certainly would be grateful to hear
about it um
and i think you can say that i think
anybody can say that and meet it
what about with one that can be
sometimes when the topic lends itself
more to the ideas of experts and who
counts as an expert it can get much more
dicey so for example let's we could
think about coveting vaccines right
where
there's not only a disagreement about
facts there's a disagreement or
misunderstanding about
who is a valid authority
and about the differences between facts
and opinions oftentimes what are
opinions are
put out there as if it is the type of
statement that counts as a fact when
really it's only an opinion and it seems
that it's a much tougher hill to climb
seemingly armed only with the socratic
method of questioning how might would
the would the application be different
in such circumstances
well i i don't think so because you can
still ask questions about other
situations where people defer to experts
like you might say um
let's talk about some are there are
there any vaccines you do take well why
do you take those
uh are there situations where expert
opinions are enough for you
because there are for me and i think
actually most of us defer to experts
sometimes
and so the question is uh when and can
you find a case where the answer is yes
and then what are the features of that
case and then how do the features of
that case compare to the features of the
the case and the case that's in
controversy i think that that's the
socratic idea is you always try to find
something
that's try go move over to an easier
case where you can agree and then
establish some things you can agree on
because usually what's going on is in
the controversial case everybody's
judgment is clouded by other features of
it by the politics of it or the the
rooting interests that you have like
almost like as a sports fan
um and so you're trying to go find a
case that's not clouded by those things
and establish your principles there and
then gently move them over into the case
that's giving everybody more trouble
what about specifically when
where the sometimes the struggle will be
when people will call me
i might present
what are you know what i see as data and
reports about a particular issue and
someone will say
well my experience is just different so
it's an anecdote right we're talking
about anecdotes versus uh empiricism and
it's very easy and reflexive to say
that's an anecdote and we need to just
look at we need to look at broader
evidence but people are often pretty
resistant to that they'll say no i mean
listen this is what i experienced and so
this is real to me in some sense
what sort of advice do you have in that
type of situation
well i i mean i think first just just
listen to people i mean nobody's going
to listen to you unless they feel like
you listen to them so if your immediate
reaction is obvious contempt for their
experience then you're just not going to
be off to an effective start but let's
imagine that you you've done that and i
think at that point maybe the most
helpful way to reason is to to to ask
well how do they feel when people make
similar claims
uh that are anecdotal or about their own
experience
but who they don't agree with i mean you
know because that's the kind of claim
that people can't stand when it's made
by those on the other side so trying to
think of an example i mean that's what i
think in general is if you can flip the
politics in a situation like imagine
exactly what you're saying but imagine
somebody on the other side
making that claim what you know you can
ask me what would you say to them what
would you think of the strength of that
claim i mean wouldn't i i'm not i'm not
trying to tell you how you feel but how
do you think how do you think you'd feel
and of course it's always perfect if you
can think of an actual example
and say well you know what you're saying
reminds me of somebody i knew and that
you may have heard about who actually
made a very similar claim but except
that they
they love everything you hate
and i just wonder how would you work
with that person and say well that
person's just wrong
well i know you think that but they
don't they don't think that's what would
you know i guess i guess what you
probably say to them is their ideas
about what counts as evidence don't seem
very strong
and then maybe you've got an inroad i
mean these are hard these are not
conversations that uh you know you can
expect in which you can expect to turn
somebody 180 degrees the question is can
you make a little headway yeah it seems
that it's although there is a sort of
socratic toolbox that it's really more
of a framework is that fair to say than
a sort of how-to
yeah that's right i mean it is there is
sort of a toolbox there are a lot of
techniques that socrates uses but it's
also just a mindset and a stance of sort
of humility and awareness of your own
arrogance and ignorance you're trying to
uh learn from others in in good faith um
so i i don't think it's a paint by
numbers scheme for questioning but if
you do study the method in the book the
socratic method that i've written tries
to provide some sort of guidance on that
i think it provides you with an approach
to hard conversations that can be more
productive than just arguing with people
directly and
contradicting them
is there a connection uh beyond just
what seems to be superficially a little
bit of overlap between
uh socrates and and stoicism
well i i would say so the stoics regard
and when you talk about stoicism of
course you're talking about the
philosophy the word stoicism in modern
english has a sort of a meaning of grim
endurance suffering or being unfeeling
and and ancient stoicism is a much
richer more interesting set of ideas
than that it's really not what it's
about and i think it's very rewarding uh
body of thought the stoics regarded
socrates as their hero and they thought
they were descendants of his indeed i
think if you're interested in stoicism
uh one one feature of the book on the
socratic method is sort of a meant to be
helpful in helping show what the origins
of the great stoic ideas were because
most of them can be traced back to uh
things socrates said
if we go back to that era and and you
know we think about
uh the trial and execution of socrates
does that tell us something about just
the general distaste many have to have
their beliefs questioned
well no doubt it does i mean the um
it's it's important i think when you're
thinking thinking about
the ancient world not to imagine these
were the good old days of unfettered
discourse you know you can some people
would say socrates was the first
victim of uh cancel culture he was like
canceled pretty good i i just think the
way i put it is the socratic mindset is
is never going to be
the majority mindset because it's it's
too contrary to how human nature works
people fundamentally crave confirmation
of what they think by others so
somebody's asking questions that are
uncomfortable is never going to be
popular wasn't popular 2500 years ago
isn't popular now uh but i think it's a
very noble and important role and it's
also i'd say the same thing about any
individual the socratic function or the
socratic aspect of your own mind is
never going to be the predominant one
because even in the site even in your
own psyche just like in the social world
it's it's it's never uh the strongest
force you know it's always sort of a
minority position but i think everybody
can use a stronger socratic attitude
within their own self as well as
finding use in the socratic method when
they're dealing with others
the book is the socratic method a
practitioner's handbook we've been
speaking with the book's author ward
farnsworth who's dean of the university
of texas law school i really appreciate
your time today
thank you david great to be here i
appreciate yours